[Musique]
porte-avions sous-marin chasseur blindé
capable d'intervenir partout dans le
monde sur terre dans les airs et en mer
la France est la première puissance
militaire d'Europe elle peut s'appuyer
sur ses forces armées pour faire
respecter le droit et faire entendre sa
voix
pierre angulaire de ses équipements
militaires la Direction générale de
l'armement c'est elle qui est chargée
d'équiper les forces armées aujourd'hui
elle porte une centaine de programmes
d'armement et à consacrer plus de 13
milliards d'euros de commandes à
l'industrie en 2020
mais comment sont conçus ces grands
programmes qui permettent à nos armées
de conduire les opérations d'aujourd'hui
et répondre aux conflit de demain pour
comprendre le rôle clé de ces programmes
d'armement remontons l'histoire de la
Cinquième République de 1960 à nos jours
au fil de ses grands programmes qui font
de la France une puissance militaire
crédible et écoutée dans le concert des
nations
[Musique]
derrière cette enceinte ultra sécurisée
se cache l'un des laboratoires les plus
confidentiels du ministère des armées
situées en Normandie il fait partie des
10 centres d'expertise et décès de la
Direction générale de l'armement ce
centre dédié aux techniques
hydrodynamique abritent une
infrastructure rare au monde un bassin
de près de 600 mètres de long il permet
de mesurer les effets de la mer sur les
bâtiments de la Marine nationale comme
les frégates les sous-marins ou le
porte-avions exceptionnellement nous
avons accès à ce centre d'excellence
lors des tous premiers tests du futur
porte-avion nouvelle génération le
successeur du Charles de Gaulle à ce
stade il s'agit d'une maquette de 10
mètres de long une reproduction réduite
au 30e mais à l'identique du futur
porte-avion nucléaire français je vous
présente la maquette du futur
porte-avion nouvelle génération au stade
d'études où on en est cette maquette
elle a servi à faire des essais dans le
bassin de 600 mètres
de résistance à l'avancement et d'auto
propulsion ça a permis notamment de
déterminer à ce stade du projet la
puissance qu'il fallait mettre à bord du
navire pour propulser le navire à la
vitesse souhaitée
[Musique]
contrairement à n'importe quel véhicule
un porte-avion est unique il n'existe
aucun prototype à taille réelle
[Musique]
0 maintenant
on est bien elles ont pas que des tests
sur maquette ils sont complètement
complémentaires décède simulation
numérique qui permet d'optimiser les
formes du navire et des hélices
cependant il est indispensable de se
confronter à la réalité de temps en
temps donc il faut faire des essais sur
ma quête à chaque étape du projet dans
la conception de développement et de la
réalisation afin de déterminer ce que
sera la performance à la mer pour
réaliser les essais nécessaires rien de
mieux que ce bassin capable de générer
de la houle avec des creux de vagues
d'un mètre soit l'équivalent d'une mer
déchaînée
l'influence de l'eau sur la coque sur la
ligne de flottaison et sur la propulsion
du navire et passer au crible rien n'est
laissé au hasard
et ce sont sous les yeux attentifs de
près de 130 experts spécialisés en
ingénierie hydrodynamique en simulation
numérique en électronique ou encore en
acoustique que se dessine les premiers
attributs du futur porte-avions
[Musique]
quand ils rejoindra la mer en 2038 ce
futur fleuron de la marine nationale
mesurera 300 mètres de long et pèsera
75000 tonnes un géant des mers qui
pourra atteindre 27 nœuds soit près de
50 km heure
un porte-avion endurant aussi grâce à sa
propulsion nucléaire résultat il pourra
accomplir davantage de missions tout au
long de l'année
sur la scène internationale le
porte-avions c'est un morceau de la
France qui se déplace
c'est aussi un concentré de puissance
qui est extrêmement démonstratif assez
peu de nations dispose ce type de
capacité et le fait que la France décide
de l'employer ou de ne pas l'employer
c'est un message assez fort le
porte-avions c'est la possibilité de
transporter les Ford françaises partout
dans le monde et tant que nous ne nous
résignions pas à être un petit pays
européen et ce n'est pas le cas et bien
le porte-avion est un élément majeur de
cette politique militaire et
diplomatique qu'il s'agisse du
porte-avion des sous-marins ou encore du
Rafale chaque programme d'armement et le
fruit d'une maturation stratégique en
moyenne il faut une vingtaine d'années
pour concevoir et développer des
équipements militaires aussi importants
en charge de l'équipement des forces
armées la DGA la Direction générale de
l'armement
on sait l'organisation à l'intérieur du
ministère des armées qui fait en sorte
que les armées aient les armements dont
on a besoin et que les officiers
désormais souhaitent donc nous sommes si
vous voulez une des points d'un triangle
un triangle qui est constitué de la DGA
que nous sommes les armées et puis
l'industrie la DGA donc il fait réaliser
l'industrie qui réalise et les armées
qui expriment le besoin et qui réception
ni faut qu'elle vérifie effectivement
que ce que nous les verrons à l'issue du
processus de préparation de
développement correspond effectivement à
leurs besoins
et si la France dispose d'un modèle
d'armée complet qui fait d'elle la
première puissance militaire d'Europe
aujourd'hui c'est le fruit d'une volonté
politique qui remonte aux années 60
au coeur des trentes glorieuses la
France est en paix avec ses voisins elle
profite du plan emploi et se met dans
des années heureuses marqués par le
développement des biens de consommation
de l'essor du prêt-à-porter et les
années
de la guerre froide un événement majeur
va dessiner un nouveau destin à la
France après les États-Unis l'URSS et le
Royaume-Uni la France devient en 1960
une puissance nucléaire
ce qui ne tardera plus guère
nous aurons
d'autant plus de moyens
pour faire sentir notre action
dans les domaines qui nous sont chers
et qui sont utiles à tous les hommes
c'est à dire la sécurité mondiale
et aussi le désarme synonyme d'autonomie
et d'indépendance le nucléaire sera un
catalyseur d'énergie de recherche et
d'innovation pour le général de Gaulle
la dissuasion nucléaire et la clé d'une
défense nationale indépendante et
souveraine
un objectif est alors fixé dotez la
France d'une force de frappe c'est dans
ce contexte que l'ancêtre de la DGA voit
le jour en 1961 on l'appelle alors la
délégation ministérielle pour l'armement
quelles sont les raisons de la création
de cette administration unique la
délégation municipale pour leur moment
il y en a une qui est le désir d'aboutir
à ce que l'on appelait l'époque une
force de frappe et cette capacité c'est
d'abord construite effectivement sur la
force de dissuasion c'est le général de
Gaulle qu'il a voulu qui a voulu doter
la France d'une force de dissuasion
capable de donner à notre pays la
puissance et la capacité de se défendre
quel que soit les circonstances et c'est
à partir de là que toute la DGA s'est
construite
pour répondre à ses ambitions politiques
technologiques et scientifiques la
France rassemble sous une même direction
tous les organismes militaires de
recherche et de fabrication d'armement
alors que jusqu'à présent chaque armée
fabriquée son propre matériel
[Musique]
à l'époque qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire on
sait qu'on a l'arme nucléaire puisque
c'est comme ça qu'on l'appelle
maintenant il va falloir le moyen de la
transporter c'est-à-dire d'abord des
avions ensuite des missiles or les
missiles ils sont lièrent ni terre ni
maire et l'électronique qui permet de
les guider n'est plus nièrent ni terre
ni mère et ça c'est une deuxième
justification à la création de la
délégation ministérielle pour leur
moment c'est que les techniques
deviennent transversales sont alors
pensées et développés des programmes
pour véhiculer la bombe à l'image du
bombardier mirage 4 qui entre au service
actifs en 1964 ou encore le premier
sous-marin nucléaire lanceur d'engins le
redoutable mise à l'eau à Cherbourg en
1967 dans les airs mais également sous
les mers et à terre la dissuasion
devient une réalité
je pense que ce n'est que dans les
années 70 puis dans les années 80 que la
dissuasion est devenue l'élément majeur
de la politique militaire française la
pointe de diamant comme disait monsieur
Mitterrand la dissonance sur l'ensemble
des domaines qu'il s'agissent des
matériels de l'armée l'air des matériels
de la marine ou encore des matériels de
l'armée de terre aussi donc on peut
trouver effectivement des expériences
acquises au titre de la diffusion qui
ont permis la réalisation des systèmes
qui sont aujourd'hui la force de notre
pays dans son modèle d'armée complet la
recherche autour de ces grands
programmes liés à la dissuasion va avoir
des répercussions directes sur les armes
conventionnelles et ceux dans tous les
domaines balistique aéronautique naval
et terrestre de nombreux programmes sont
alors lancés ils entreront plus tard
dans les forces parmi eux les missiles
antichard les avions Mirage 2000
les véhicules blindés amx-10rc ou encore
les corvettes anti sous-marines
l'objectif est clair composé un modèle
d'armée complet c'est à dire capable
d'intervenir dans tous les milieux
le modèle d'armée qui a été décidé pour
la France c'est un objectif stratégique
et chaque capacité individuellement
concours à l'obtention de ce modèle
complet défini par la stratégie de
défense française et donc il faut
s'assurer que il manque pas une capacité
que l'ensemble des capacités est
cohérence qu'il n'y a pas de doublon et
qu'il n'y a pas de trou développer des
équipements militaires nécessitent une
lecture attentive de l'histoire pour une
meilleure anticipation des menaces et
conflits futures entre le moment où on
commence à développer ou à imaginer la
solution et le moment où elle arrive en
service dans les armées effectivement
c'est entre 15 et 20 ans souvent et donc
il faut savoir que ce que sont les
menaces alors anticiper les menaces ça
se fait par la réflexion stratégique
d'une façon générale beaucoup de
discussions avec les utilisateurs les
armées qui voient les choses évoluer de
leur côté dans les armées évidemment les
services de renseignement ceux qui
évaluent la menace la menace future et
puis énormément de discussions avec la
DGA et au travers de la DG avec les
industriels
pour déterminer ce qui est accessible
pour faire évoluer les capacités dans
nos disposons ou dont nous souhaitons
disposer dans l'avenir
parmi tous les matériels entrés en
service actifs dans les forces certains
sont devenus emblématiques au fil des
opérations comme le déjà mythique avion
rafale à l'origine du programme au début
des années 80 l'armée de l'air et la
Marine nationale expriment un besoin
remplacer 7 types d'avions de combat
différent par un seul et même chasseur
multirose
pour l'armée de l'air il s'agit de
remplacer ces jaguars et ses mirages
et pour l'aéronavale ses Crusaders et
Super Étendard
l'enjeu est immense
le Rafale devra aussi bien effectuer des
missions de permanence opérationnelle de
sécurité du territoire de frappes dans
la profondeur d'appui aériens de
reconnaissance et de dissuasion
l'aventure débute dans les bureaux
d'études de Dassault en 1983 trois ans
plus tard le prototype du Rafale a
effectué son premier vol sur le site
d'essai de la DGA à Istres et rencontre
ses premiers succès au salon du Bourget
c'est une bonne préfiguration de la
viande l'an 2000 ce n'est qu'un
démonstrateur lorsque nous aurons le
véritable avion ça sera vraiment on
tombe dans les avions de l'an 2000
s'ensuit une succession de campagnes
d'essai pour améliorer toujours un peu
plus l'appareil
20 ans plus tard le Rafale entre au
service actif
[Musique]
très vite il fait ses preuves en
opération en Afghanistan en Libye au
Mali en Irak ou encore en Syrie
[Musique]
le lieutenant-colonel Clément a fait
toute sa carrière sur rafale cette
aviateur chevronné compte pas moins de
2000 heures de vol sur l'appareil
aujourd'hui il est officier programme
Rafale au sein de l'Armée de l'Air et de
l'Espace sa mission continuer à
améliorer cet appareil tout jeune j'ai
découvert cet avion d'abord de loin et
dès mes premières heures sur avion de
combat je les ai passés sur rafale par
la suite j'ai participé aux opérations
pendant de longues décennies les avions
de combat étaient dédiés à une mission
spécifique
et le Rafale a cette capacité
remarquable de faire l'ensemble des
missions d'évolus à l'armée aérienne
suivant la situation
en Afghanistan c'était un peu le baptême
de combat pour le Rafale la Libye a été
la mise en place nombreux types de
missions notamment la reconnaissance a
pu être appliquée les attaques dans la
profondeur la défense aérienne ça a été
la maturité et aujourd'hui on a une
connexion avec nos alliés qui est
vraiment améliorée
[Musique]
le besoin des forces ça reste toujours
le même combat il s'agit d'améliorer
notre bouclier d'améliorer notre épée de
s'adapter aux nouvelles technologies et
permettre une compréhension encore
accrue du champ de bataille pour prendre
les meilleures décisions
la DGA est bien c'est l'architecte de ce
bel avion qu'elle aura fan c'est aussi
le fruit de leur travail je crois que le
succès de Rafale il repose sur la
capacité que nous avons voulu lui donner
dès le départ d'être un avion capable
d'accomplir les différentes missions que
l'on demande à un avion de chasse donc
je pense que le concept même d'avion qui
a été choisi par la France au démarrage
du programme c'est avéré le bon l'autre
chose effectivement c'est que le Rafale
avait été conçu pour être évolutif pour
prendre en compte des possibilités
nouvelles désarmement nouveaux et
répondre aussi bien que possible à
l'évolution de la menace en particulier
ou des conditions d'emplois qui qui
changent en permanence au fil des
opérations et des évolutions
technologiques le plus célèbre chasseur
français qui séduit à l'export a donc
évolué pour rester à la pointe et faire
face à des menaces toujours plus
nombreuses
[Applaudissements]
au sol aussi il faut faire face en
première ligne le combattant est parfois
confronté à un ennemi mieux équipé plus
organisé ou plus intelligents
qu'auparavant il est donc nécessaire de
toujours mieux protéger les soldats et
ce dans des délais plus courts que pour
les grands programmes d'armement une
autre facette de l'activité de la
Direction générale de l'armement des
méthodes dites d'urgence opérationnelle
qui consiste effectivement à livrer le
plus vite possible les matériels qui
s'avèrent absolument nécessaires sur les
terres d'opération en particulier donc
c'est ce que nous appelons les processus
d'urgence opération la réactivité est un
une recherche permanente les programmes
militaires ont la fâcheuse tendance de
durer plusieurs plusieurs années voire
plusieurs dizaines d'années donc on a
développé
un certain nombre de procédures qui
permettent de sélectionner les besoins
les plus urgents à partir d'un retour de
terrain et d'une analyse de terrain qui
valide ce besoin et puis un certain
nombre de choses qui permettent de
détecter les bonnes idées et de les
mettre en service le plus rapidement
possible donc c'est là que c'est là
qu'on peut faire preuve de réactivité la
recrudescence des engins explosifs
improvisés et des tirs de roquettes en
Afghanistan ont poussé les ingénieurs de
la DGA et les armées à réagir rapidement
[Musique]
par un combat classique de haute
intensité tel qu'on pourrait l'imaginer
et c'est effectivement quelque chose que
nous devons assurer en permanence donc
tout ça fait que effectivement ça
nécessite non seulement des études dans
mon projet mais également des
développements technologiques qui font
partie de nos programmes de nos
programmes innovation nos programmes
d'étudemment que nous poursuivons d'une
année sur l'autre
pour faciliter les échanges les états
majeurs ont été regroupés en 2015 au
sein d'un seul et même site à Balard
dans le 15e arrondissement de Paris
[Musique]
au sein d'un espace commun les
opérationnels peuvent ainsi échanger
avec la Direction générale de l'armement
sur la conception de nouvelles capacités
pour être toujours plus efficient sur le
terrain
donc ça nous le faisons un étroitre
relation avec les armées nous avons
rapproché tout dernièrement les équipes
des états majeurs et d'un autre maison
des géants qui travaillent ici
physiquement à Balard nous avons mis
dans un sur un plateau commun de manière
à ce qu'effectivement ce travail de
d'élaboration du système à réaliser se
fasse de manière aussi efficace que
possible ensuite une fois que ce travail
de préparation est fait et bien il faut
effectivement faire en sorte que les
cycles longues soient conciliés avec
l'efficacité de la réponse aux besoins
dans la réponse aux besoins des armées
l'innovation c'est un sujet dont on
parle beaucoup l'innovation elle est
constante dans les développements de des
capacités militaires
en Afghanistan hier au Sahel aujourd'hui
les armées sont engagées en opération
sans discontinuer depuis 20 ans avec les
retours d'expérience accumulées et la
part grandissante du cyber et des
nouvelles technologies la DGA et les
forces ont convergé vers une priorité
rendre le champ de bataille plus lisible
pour le combattant et son commandement
cette volonté s'illustre notamment par
la conception de véhicules
interconnectés entre eux
c'est le sens du programme phare de
l'armée de terre le programme Scorpion
il est destiné à renouveler et
moderniser les capacités de l'armée de
terre avec notamment des blindés
nouvelle génération
un nouveau blindé rejoindra les rangs de
l'armée de terre en 2022 le véhicule
blindé multiro léger baptisé Serval avec
le griffon il remplacera le véhicule de
l'avant blindé qui prendra une retraite
bien méritée après avoir foulé pendant
40 ans les plaines yougoslave
les vallées afghans
et la latérite africaine
pour l'heure le serval est encore en
face de test au sein du Centre
d'expertise et décès de la DGA
spécialisée pour les véhicules
terrestres l'antenne danger est composée
d'une centaine de personnes
tout se passe bien alors sur le site
d'Angers il y a deux grands types
d'essais en fait qui sont qui sont menés
les premiers essais ce sont les essais
en environnement climatique et
vibratoires donc avec des chambres
climatiques et puis des pistes spéciales
qui permettent de solliciter
mécaniquement le véhicule et la deuxième
famille d'essai ce sont des essais de
sécurité du roulage donc des essais
routiers où on va dérouler un certain
nombre de modes opératoires
les résultats déposés
effectivement mais on va aller voir tout
de suite une fois livré par l'industriel
la DGA effectue des tests avant sa mise
en service afin de s'assurer que ce
véhicule de 17 tonnes et conforme aux
exigences des forces armées c'est ce
qu'on appelle la phase de qualification
essaie de résistance de durabilité de
compatibilité électromagnétique
d'aérotransportabilité le nouveau
véhicule est examiné sous toutes les
coutures on aura plusieurs capteurs à
installer sur le véhicule donc on a un
capteur qui va nous donner de l'angle du
volant donc on démontra le volant du
véhicule et on mettra ce capteur et le
pilote lui il aura cet écran là
l'affichage et aussi on lui dit de
mettre une consigne d'angle et ben voilà
il mettra par exemple 115-175 on fait
les différents essais qui qui sont
demandés et après on ressort des courbes
et des fichiers des fichiers résultats
aux responsables d'essai ok on va
maintenant à ce moment-là une manœuvre
forte sollicitation de type évitement
rabattement
sur les pistes de ce site de 150
hectares le serval est poussé dans ses
retranchements
au programme test de vitesse de freinage
des vêtements et de franchissement
des sensations de roulis le tangage
toutes ces sensations qu'on peut
ressentir dans une voiture sont beaucoup
plus amplifiées dans un véhicule lourd
surtout typiquement de combat comme
celui-là après l'ambiance sonore qui est
très très différente elle aussi plus
métallique
mais après la conduite reste assez
proche d'un poids lourd assez classique
mon métier c'est opérateur d'essai
mobilité et c'est un métier déjà
vraiment à part entière on est unique en
Europe et on en est très fier un métier
qui qui s'apprend sur plusieurs années
on est de pouvoir valider avant de
pouvoir mieux maîtriser correctement les
bons gestes et surtout les gestes de
sécurité
on fait vraiment un métier de
d'exception
on a quand même vocation à couvrir un
peu près tout le spectre de ce qui est
possible pour le véhicule ce qui fait
qu'un véhicule comme celui-ci on va on
va faire du routier évidemment on va
faire de la boue on va faire du sable
qui est très en lien avec les opérations
du moment mais on va aussi
potentiellement faire de la rocaille on
va faire potentiellement aussi de la
neige sur les configurations de chaînage
par exemple c'est vraiment notre raison
d'être ici c'est de faire en sorte que
le matériel qui est livré au force
répondre à leurs exigences et puis
surtout une présente pas de risque pour
eux et pour les tirs
une fois l'ensemble des tests validés le
serval devrait rejoindre le griffon à
l'horizon 2022 il permettra ainsi aux
armées d'être encore un peu plus
performante sur le terrain et aux
soldats d'être mieux protégé
engagé en faveur de la protection du
combattant et résolument tourné vers
l'avenir la DGA assu en 60 ans
d'existence se mettre au service des
armées pour lui garantir un modèle
complet grâce à sa base industrielle et
technologique de défense et ses
coopérations européennes aussi bien sur
terre
que dans les airs et sur les mers elle
s'est attachée à doter nos armées des
meilleures équipement possible à mesure
des développements technologiques et des
nouvelles menaces et ceci pour une
ambition permettre à la France de mener
à bien des opérations et de répondre aux
conflit de demain effectivement la DGA
pendant ces 60 ans ça a été un outil
essentiel au développement de nos
capacités de défense et donc à la
défense et à l'indépendance de notre
pays et je crois que le défi que nous
avons c'est effectivement de continuer
pendant alors c'est pas les 60 ans à
venir peut-être ce que nous avons pu
réaliser ce que les équipes de la DGA
qui encore une fois c'est elle renforce
la DGA ce sont ces femmes et ces hommes
qui ont constituent la substance ce que
qui a été fait pendant ces 60 ans le
pérenniser dans les années à venir au
service de nos armées et au service de
notre pays
[Musique]